[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nostalgie
toutes les cloches des
églis sonne le GL de nos
campagne je
sais que nos miroirs se
[Musique]
pris au mur du château de
versaill
je suis la forêt de
SL et T ces chaînes
qu'onat je suis le dernier ser de France
qu'on attend au bout d'un
fusil tu
voista ce train qui travers les villages
de
montagne et les ont laissé rouiller mes
RA alors je vi là je couris là tout seul
dans un
hangar je veux mourir en
pyramide devant l'Égypte et ses
trésors plutôt que vivre vivre vivre en
[Musique]
polaroïde sur une photo
technicolog et je pense à toi monsieur
mermos mais la BA de Rio a bien changé
tu sais aujourd'hui l'aventure c'est
autre chose n'est-ce pas un petit
bonhomme dansand n pas de dessiné et h
un
[Musique]
hos aujourd'hui les corniers ça fait
sourire et et la Terre de Feu est en
exile le temps le temps le temps le
temps le temps rien le temps le temps le
temps le temps le temp le temps le temps
le temps aujourd'hui c'est demain le
temps le temp le temps le temps le temps
le temp et dans nos
vies
solitaire on est des gens pas
[Musique]
ordinaire e e je pense à toi donc qui
chte de la Manche et je cours oh s je
cours je cours je cours je cours et oui
je cours après tes moulins avant et
qu'est-ce qu'on me dit e tu sais ce
qu'on me dit que je suis fou mais oui
fou comme ces hommes qui font la guerre
mais qui n' plus se battre en duel on n
regarde on n même plus des animaux on
est déjà des robots des robots e des
robots l'amour n'existe que dans les
livres dans les
livres
dshabillé tout en
[Musique]
couleur mais les jeunes filles en
crinoline etimz les oiseaux et les
fleurs et moi oh
moi je n'ai plus que la musique et des
chansons pour leur parler mais
moi moi je serai le dernier
romantique avant que l'ordinateur machin
mais mais définitivement déprogrammé
mais moi moi si tu me donnes un
arcenciel mais mais jeai des châteaux
forts dans les bruves et dans les
horor ma nostalgie est
[Musique]
différente on m'a pas fait de ir non
moi je suis un enfant qui
invente je n'ai vécu qu'
[Musique]
venir on nous a trop souvent menti avec
des chiffres avec des tes qui ne
voulaient rien dire avec des rois des
empereurs des présidents des murs de
Berlin et des murailles de Chine mais
les murs ne servaient plus à rien les
murs il serait temps qu'on vous le dise
mais oui vous parlez trop nous avons
besoin de silence aujourd'hui tout est
chronométré la vie l'amour la mort mais
on ne pourra même plus battre nos
propres records et il faudra bien les
casser les chronomètrre et vivre vivre
vivre vivre au rythme des saisons pour
quand je pense qu'on nous amuse avec des
satellites avec des nouvelles planètes
alors qu'ici on fousille tout les forêts
les océans les rivières le cœur des
hommes mais oui les hommes pour ne
s'intéresse à eux qu'on premier attentat
aujourd'hui est la misère ça dérange
n'est-ce pas et nos consciences si elle
pouvait se déranger aussi souvent que
nos
téléphones je ne veux plus croire en nos
croyance oh
non d'un Dieu pour chaque
religion s'il y en a un qui nous
alors qu'il chante avec moi ma
[Musique]
chanson je tu parle à toi qui dans ton
bureau dans ton usine ou sur un
tracteur oui moi je chante pour les
hommes du Nouveau Monde moi pour toi
Péro de Madrid de Milan Jérémy de San
Francisco pour vous dire
quoi et bien pour vous dire que j'ai
peur oui peur peur de ces avions qui
vont trop vite de ces pays que je ne
rencontrerai
jamais je ne veux plus que nos paroles
soient entendues comme une langue
étrangère non non je ne veux
plus moi je veux que nous ayons le temps
de vivre tous le temps de sentir le
soleil qui nous brûle et le vent qui
nous
décoiffe le temps de regarder les
abeilles les
écureuils le temps de parler à nos
enfants le temps le temps d'oublier la
terreur la violence la bêtise oh la
bêtise moi je veux que les hommes
redeviennent des hommes et la terre un
vrai un grand
jardin et que la paix soit dans nos
cœurs et que notre volonté soit
faite
nostalgie nostalgie planète Terre
planète Dieu j'irai vers
toi prendre ma
[Musique]
place